- So Nicola, Justin have
y'all ever met each other?
- No.
- No, never.
- Never, oh my gosh
- But good to meet you.
Meet in quotes, good to meet you.
- Yeah.
(host laughs)
- Justin, have you seen Bridgerton?
- I have, I've dabbled
and I agree with you.
It's one of those things where
if you watch that show,
you gotta commit to it
because you're gonna be
sitting there for a while.
- Yes.
- It's hard to
get your eyes off of it.
- Yes well also it sets a bar, Nicola
like by the end of it
I was a tad bit angry
because I was like,
that's never gonna happen in real life.
(laughing)
It's the most amazing,
whoa, it's really good.
So if you've watched it then
you get where I'm going.
Where are you calling
from right now Nicola?
- So I'm calling from
Galway, the west of Ireland.
I'm actually in my mom's house right now
beside the fancy lamp.
You know, you've gotta
show off the nice things
when you come on television.
So I've been on lockdown
with my mom since March,
since we wrapped Bridgerton pretty much.
- Well, yeah, you would've
had to have taped that show
pre COVID cause no test yet.
- There's not much social
distancing in Bridgerton
no it's very..
- Yeah, no testing in the
world would've covered that.
But no, I love you and also
I have to mention this,
I love you in "Derry Girls" as well.
The other Netflix show you--
- Oh my God.
- Yeah it's so great.
I love you in both.
- I did not know you've--
Oh, thank you so much.
That's so kind.
- Yeah--
- I mean very different shows.
- Then that's what I loved as well.
I loved that they were
completely different
and your personality in both are amazing.
And you do a really great job of
kinda taking over the scenes
in the best way possible.
I mean that in the best way possible
but were you performing as a kid?
- Oh, I loved it so much.
My brother bought me a video camera
when I was about nine years old
and I became like a tyrant
making my own home movies
and getting my friends to
like do the "Spice Girls."
There we are doing "2 Become 1"
I was Pa spice,
(laughing)
and then my best friend
May was baby spice.
(Nicola laughing)
And yeah, I was totally like a dictator
when it came to directing
and we used to recreate
episodes with friends
and all this kinda other
stuff, but we just, yeah
I loved it so much.
- Oh man, I loved that too.
I was the same kind of kid.
We were always doing stuff like that.
That was so embarrassing
that I would never want to show anyone.
Whose dog was that?
Which dog was that?
Was that Paisley?
(Kelly laughs)
- That's Paisley.
She's hey, it's COVID what do you want?
(Kelly laughs)
She's having moment, sorry.
- No, I love it.
- Am glad cause for a second
I was like, do I have a dog?
(conversing indistinctly)
But maybe I have a dog.
- It's like a Wolf.
She's like she needs the attention.
Sorry, she's yeah--
- I pointed it out coz I think it's funny.
I literally had to shoot in my
house this show at some point
and my dog, Henry, I was like,
he would just roam through the scene.
I was like, well, okay.
But Nicola, we also have
this picture you posted.
Can you explain what's
what's happening here?
- Yes, absolutely.
So this was, I went to drama school
at the Oxford School of Drama
and people had to write
a list of what characters
they thought we'd be good at.
And you know, there was like nerdy friend
which was Claire from "Derry Girls"
and there was walked over
person, Imperial drama,
which is Penelope in "Bridgerton."
So they got those right.
And then one was like alcoholic,
and am like, okay
(Kelly laughs)
Like maybe it's coz I
was the only Irish person
in the class and I
enjoyed drinking Guinness.
Though they were like we
know what she is and yeah
(laughing)
- That's normal.
- I haven't done that yet
maybe that will be my next role.
- I just love that person.
Like, you know what you're
gonna nail, alcoholic.
You're gonna nail that one.
(laughing)
That's awesome.
Well Nicola, congrats on
the success of Bridgerton.
It's just taking over.
- Thank you.
- How great though, is
the diversity on the show?
That's what I loved about it mostly.
- It's so incredible.
I mean, it's a thing that
we haven't seen enough of
Imperial dramas, not even close
and it's a Shondaland land show
and Shondaland have done so much
in terms of diversity on television.
So a period drum of theirs would be,
you know following in that path.
And I think before the show came out
there were some naysayers
and people that were trying to like
download it on IMDB
because they didn't like
the fact it was diverse.
But then we were watched
by 63 million households.
So I'm like, well that shows
that people do like diversity on screen.
There you go.
- Yeah, it's so great.
So true or false,
I heard that you stabbed
one of your co-stars?
So that's weird.
(Kelly laughs)
- Unfortunately that is true.
(Nicola laughs)
So it was my first day on set
and it's quite terrifying getting a big
Shondaland Netflix job.
You think I just don't
wanna screw this up.
So they said to me
you're very tiny, let's
let's put you in heels
and I thought, yeah
I'll do anything you want me to do.
It became evident pretty quickly that
with the corset and the heels,
my balance was not so amazing.
So I was walking along
and I fell three times.
And the third time I was holding a parasol
which in the wrong
hands is a deadly weapon
and I fell forward and
stabbed Claudia Jesse
who plays Eloise Bridgerton in the hand
and she just started bleeding.
(laughing)
- Oh my gosh.
- But she's still my friend.
She's still my friend.
But yeah unfortunately
there was a stabbing
on the first day and I was guilty.
It was not good.
- I mean, my thing is if I'm
wearing those long dresses,
anytime I'm on a stage
and it's a long dress,
I look at my stylist and go,
I want the easiest shoes in the world,
coz they can't even see your feet.
So I don't even know why--
- Just throw yourself on the ground Kelly
that's all you need to do.
Just be like, oh, throwing yourself over
and then you'll never
have to wear heels again.
- Yeah.